[MUSIC]
Many reapplicants worry that they are at
a disadvantage to first time applicants.
Is that true?
And do you have any advice for
people who kind of reapply?
>> We really read them fresh.
So my best advise is, the person
who is evaluating your application
likely is never seen it before.
So there's no reason to explain
what's different or what's changed or
maybe why you think you didn't get in,
some people will try to tell us that.
Just start fresh and
look at what you've already submitted.
You don't have to change everything, but
think is there something at this moment
in time that could be more compelling.
Perhaps in the last, or something you want
to change to be more representative of
where I am at this moment.
But please do, if you're committed
to Stanford reapply because there's
a lot of students that we
admit from that category.
>> Some of my favorite
classmates are reapplications.
>> They told you.
[LAUGH]
>> So I'm really glad-
>> That's great.
>> That they're here.
>> That's awesome.